all right Rob how are you rob uh where'd
you grow up where you from uh South
planfield New Jersey South planfield
yeah and you grew up with Mom and Dad
yeah my mom and dad yep I have a brother
who's four years older Paul yeah how was
your
childhood childhood was you know um it
was good I had a I had a good support
system parents are married they're a
great great family you know being with
my mother was Puerto Rican so you know
have a Puerto Rican mother you know you
[__] up they'll get you so yeah you know
other than that she was a you know good
mother but you know if you went out of
line she definitely took care of
business so you [__] up at church you
better you better walk home cuz uh if
she walked home you're in trouble yeah
so a couple times we acted up in church
and my mom being uh you know a very
religious Catholic we messed up in
church we were doomed it was a bad it
was bad timing it was not good yeah so
and you you uh you graduated high school
graduated high school what what did you
do with your life uh let see my life um
I went to college uh went to talison
University and then um I did Roc because
I realized I was you know drinking a
little bit and I wanted to um I wanted
to you know better myself so I was
partying but I wasn't I didn't really
have Direction until I joined the
military so I did Roc at Lola College
and then I graduated as a lieutenant
second lieutenant in
1998 so yeah and you went to you there
was combat combat yes I was in Iraq
during the surge in 2007 as the captain
with the 58th if infantry Brigade combat
team and then I was in
Afghanistan
201122 with the 29 temp division so uh
with like a 58 Man team or 56 Man team
as I recall don't remember but it was a
long time ago and uh I was I was
attached to the um as an adviser to the
Cabo City police so that's where I saw a
lot of a lot of violence towards uh US
forces and Coalition forces and uh it's
pretty rough so our job was to respond
to all the terrorist attacks in kabo
Province uh make sure the the chain of
custody of evidence was handled properly
from Afghan forces to us make sure we
took phones any type of paperwork
evidence weapons any type of evidence
related to any suicide attack make sure
there was the scene was under control
and the right people were there and most
important is to keep the media away
that's very important so that was a hard
job as a as you know as I describe it
what what what are some of the most
extreme things you you saw when you were
there man I terrorist attacks I I think
the first couple weeks I was there I
responded to um a terrorist attack that
involved the Rhino bus was a
transportation bus for civilians and
soldiers to different various bases
throughout Cabell so we got a call it
was a convoy and um a van like the Back
to Future van you know already saw in
the parking lot so they turned into the
Convoy and uh killed like I think like
23 people like six people on the ground
15 like four service members US soldiers
Coalition forces from Canada and um
civilians from I don't I can't recall
the company but it was pretty bad they
were in pieces and uh that was rough I
had to carry um yeah I don't like
talking about
it yeah
but I had to carry uh some of the
soldiers out so it was it was tough
man how many years were you in the in
the
military uh like 16 12
it's a lot yeah so you know so you know
people say you know talk about the stuff
you've been through but you once you see
a lot of violence you
know it's always there when you see the
US soldiers or civilians killed
especially kids you know it changes you
it takes so toll on your mental
health so you know it's for me coun to
sayate talk about it talk about it I me
this is one of many of many
experiences and you see a lot of death
I mean as a cop you can see death uh
once a week twice a week or and you know
like I said before as a police officer
prior cop you you were a cop after you
came back no I was a cop you know with
uh my civilian my job so I was in
reserves I'm sorry in reserves I had
active duty time in college after I
graduated and then once that happened I
became a police officer in a major city
and uh like I said um in the US in the
US yeah of course in the US Metropolitan
City
and you know you can deal with death
because the people usually they're
homicide victims what I've saw are they
not really good people but you don't
want to see anybody die but when you see
soldiers that that sacrifice they leave
their families they serve your country
because it all SS back to 911 so so
there's a certain brotherhoods when you
see a Dead Soldier either Coalition or
us man it it [__] you up because you
got to wrap the flag around the body bag
and then the helicopters come and take
it that took a toll on me I did that a
few
times and
um it was rough it was rough and then
being a cop is no party either no I I I
think the uh PTSD like I told you was
probably stemming from that uh was
probably a little bit hidden but once I
went to combat in Afghanistan and all
that amount of violence probably just um
increased it and it actually came out
when you're busy in combat all these uh
factors is PTSD or health issues mental
health if you're on if you're busy all
the time the adrenaline's kicking you
can deal with stress I I would deal with
stress very good if it's
dangerous but when you come home and
you're you're out of the military you
don't have the health care you have and
you're not
working personal issues like doing like
finances and [__] like that I it was
hard for me to do
because it was hard to manage my
personal life because I would use drugs
to help help counteract the the
emotional issues I was having so it was
tough it was tough on me and I think
your childhood was there any trauma in
that that you grew up with yeah I
disciplinary
actions my mother yeah I mean it could
say a little Factor on that you know it
could you know what do you experience as
a
child it could affect you um it's
possible that I had some issues when I
was a child I I just I just wonder if
something you went through as a kid kind
of opened the door for you to put
yourself in situations that might bring
in more
trauma yeah yeah yeah it's possible it's
possible if you get um if you get
disciplined a little too much it's
possible it's good um that's a good
question and we talked about that
earlier you don't know if you know if
like you had a good question when people
with trauma become police officers
become
soldiers maybe like you said experience
the trauma over again to make you deal
with what you witnessed or experienced
when you were younger that is a good
question I don't know if there's
research on that that's a good but I
wonder that it's a good thing to you
don't know but you know most most
importantly what I found in combat is
you know the guys you serve with you
always you always will remember them or
you always communicate with them pretty
much throughout your whole life there's
always a bond you have with with the
guys men and women you men and women you
serve with so um it was tough I also
saw a lot of a lot of uh a lot of
bravery and I saw a lot of uh people
that
were um pretty much you know both count
doesn't have the US Coalition I see a
lot of when you go to war you see who's
a coward and see who's not and based on
the experiences I've been through I saw
it on both sides us and Coalition
forces um in war you can easily pick you
know the heroes and the non-hero because
uh when [__] hits the fan the people
that are constantly with you I serve a
great soldiers men and women and
uh they were there the whole time
they're with me through the whole time
I've been through a lot of [__] and it
was a team effort even my Afghan um
interpreters they were great I would
trust them more than I trust some of the
US soldiers that I worked with really
because I work with them on a daily
basis and with the Afghan culture they
have to you have to learn they have to
learn to know you you you don't know
them so they trust is is gained through
experience in that relationship it's not
like you earn it's not like it's you get
it right away you have to trust you you
have to get to know your personalities
they you know it's it's um you earn that
trust in that respect it's not given so
you
know war is definitely something that's
not good for anybody it's not good to
see it has a long-term effects on your
mental health and how you perceive
cultures and perceive life in general
it's not
easy
yeah were there any military awards when
you were serving yeah um uh our team did
excellent um you know we served our to
our best of our abilities um I received
the Bronze Star um Combat Action Badge
and the joint service Achievement medal
uh while I while I was in Afghanistan it
was team effort team
effort it was um definitely a team
effort and you you when you came back
you you were a cop for how long no I
wasn't a cop but once I came back I was
uh I was in a warrior transition unit
for several months and then uh went back
to the police department talked to
psychiatrist and they said you know
based on what you've been through it's
it would be better if you just retire so
I you know it could be it can be a
liability issue you might stop somebody
you might you know he might overreact
and it's better you know they address
the problem
rather than I go out there I make a
mistake and then it's too late right so
and what have you done with
your time since you got back well I had
a bad problem with drugs I would take a
lot of pills and do illegal substances
um but the most importantly I started
playing music so what helped me rather
than do drugs sometimes if I felt
anxiety I would play the piano and uh to
help me it helped me get better music
music for me music all around the world
people love love music and music I go
play at the VA I make my own songs uh
based on how I feel but uh I see a lot
of soldiers and Veterans like music they
like to sit and listen to the piano I
think music has a calming effect on the
mind and I think it's very important so
I can easily take the phone call call
drug and get drugs or I can go for a run
or I can play music uh that's most
important once I play music all that
stuff
is gone it goes away but but I can
easily make the wrong decision and get
drugs but I try not to so music for me
it it makes me calm it takes away the
negative uh you know the negative or
voices in my head to make bad decisions
the depression it goes away but um it's
such an easy uh fix for a serious
problem easy fix but remember I have to
make the right decision to go to the be
I can usually call up and get an
eightball I mean but who wants you know
either way I feel like [__] drugs are no
good you know and it's funny thing is
the uh when I was at the VA they gave me
so many prescription medications they
try to mask you but in reality they're
not fixing any problems it's up to you
to fix yourself if it takes running or
learning learning a hobby for me
medication man it's a it really messed
up my mind especially you mix it with
narcotics it makes you worse so for me
music has
helped my heal uh you know heal ability
to heal
inside uh inside is most importantly
mental health is most important yeah
that's wonderful were were you playing
piano before as a kid maybe a couple
land three to four years of lessons but
nothing serious so I started playing my
music again after I went to I went out
Iraq I would go to the chapel and uh
they have a piano there and I would play
so I started really playing and then
after Afghanistan I started really to
play because I was really [__] up so I
had to try to find some type of um
Avenue that was healthy enough to uh to
handle what I was going through which
was not easy you you know that makes
sense I I might go I might be rambling
but for me music has helped
me calm my inner self and most
importantly is when other veterans say
hey man that made me relax or they
listen to me it's a good thing it's a
good thing that people stop you and say
hey I like your music M which is good um
yeah I mean that's pretty much it you
Mar you've been married have kids oh
yeah yeah I'm divorced I have a a
24-year-old daughter and a 13-year-old
son son good kids great kids yeah that's
wonderful yeah and and how old are you
now
48 it's [__] 48 hip replaced it's
brutal yeah so I'm back to running again
so I got to get back in shape man
because you know depression for me comes
and goes and waves so I can be great one
day and then make a bad decision I'm on
drugs for the next week and then I'm
healthy I run another week it's amazing
cuz I like different personalities so I
would do drugs I'm like [__] it I know
it's bad B for me the next week I would
run be healthy for another two weeks
they go right back to the same badge
unhealthy choices it comes in waves kind
comes away it's amazing yeah I want to
get every drug addict wants to get
better but there's always somebody in
the back saying you know
what you
know when I first started doing drugs
people say man you deserve it you've
been through a lot that's how we try to
justify our actions who cares I'm
retired I'm not law enforcement I'm not
a leader anymore I'm doing nothing know
I'm partying which is bad to decision
because no matter what you have kids are
looking up for you looking up to you you
got people other veterans looking up to
you so it's it's it's good to stay
healthy healthy and clean is what we
want but we have like inner demons that
says hey you know get the drugs is an
easy fix to fix how you're feeling where
you're currently feeling you know do you
feel like you were always this way or or
did the PTSD that you went through in
the military or or as a cop kind of
added to it or or created it I never did
drugs as a police offer before that so
mostly my drug use is after it's all my
drug use is after combat M because I
have the ability cuz no one remember
once you're in the AR out of the army
you don't have that same Brotherhood or
or accountability so once the
accountability is gone and your purpose
and direction is gone it it doesn't
matter you're you're like Lu you're
[__] you have to
soldiers and people that get out they
have to have purpose motivation and
direction if you lose that you're pretty
much you're [__] so a lot of times I
called like General Winnington he's a
two star general General Chuck
Winnington he's a great friend he's a
he's a a solders general if you have a
problem you call him and uh he's he was
probably one of the best General
officers I ever I ever worked with or
experienced because um he's a guy that
knows how to put you in the right
position there's staff officers that are
good in briefings there's uh for me he
knows I was a police officer and my
other parter uh poo he's a d agent he's
retired so he put the law enforcement
experience in the law enforcement jobs
so he knows we excel in that because I
like catching bad people I was good at
that stuff um and that was it so he he's
a general that he always knew where to
put the right people to succeed that's
why we succeeded we we had a good unit
we're probably the best unit oh we're
all pretty tight the guys that are
served with men and women yeah it's all
about there's a lot of there also
officers in the military
that that are all about the political
side they don't want to make the
decision that for example when I was in
a situation at an attack on car Lake it
was a it was a terrorist attack that
killed about I think like 30
civilians and we responded and I was
told by a British one of the British
Military Officers that the the place was
secured it was a
hotel and um so I trusted him but I
called the Army I I called back to the
talk which is a tactical Operation
Center and say listen we need additional
assets I don't feel this is safe can you
bring you know some uh you know bomb
dogs you know people to sniff out the
dogs to sniff out any uh any uh you know
bomb residue or anything but they said
no it's the roads are black it's unsafe
so I said listen so you got military US
service members on the scene trying to
get evidence report back to the National
Police coordination Center but my own
unit my own not my own unit the unit
that was you know at the base at the
time the commander wouldn't set the
asset sent the assets to us because it
said the roads are black that's [__]
up that's [__] up so in reality I
walked in
and there were three dead bodies that
were shot were shot in the head and they
were all sitting naturally so reality is
if you can shoot somebody in your head
they're going to fall natural they're
going to fall on the ground these guys
are placed sitting up so I told the
Afghans and my guys with me that we know
don't touch the bodies don't touch them
at all until we get you know the dogs
out here clear them you know what I mean
clear the scene so the the Afghan didn't
listen the uh combat uh he was the crime
scene guy he pulls the body down and
blows his arm off there was a grenade in
the back of the body and it blew off I
mean I lost my feelings and uh my head
was ratted a little bit and but we're
okay but the thing is if the the Army if
I requested the assets I have the
experience to know what's going on they
didn't care they didn't care it was it
was it was unsafe for their soldiers to
travel to respond to us but in reality
we needed their support so and luckily
nothing really happened but that was a
[__] up situation for me so I realized
you have some great officers that are in
charge and you have some officers that
that I believe they're cowards they're
there to to make Rank and uh you know
sometimes you have to make decisions
that can put your soldiers at life in
danger but the majority of soldiers men
and women Marines Air Force Army Navy
they want to do stuff they want to be
there they want to make a difference and
um soldiers wanted you know soldiers are
the best our military is the best but
again we have you know leaders that are
not good so I don't know if I went on
too much but TR do you regret enlisting
no no no no I uh to be honest with you I
when I joined RC I never thought about
911 I got a beer stiping I thought I
thought I mean I was a major in the Army
but in reality I I didn't really care
about that stuff I was a guy you know my
my
um my personality never changed I like
the party I was very personal very
friendly with people but um but when I
joined the army RC I wanted maturity but
I had a beer stip it was 150 a month I
mean back then it was a great a lot of
money but what I got better I was a
terrible Lieutenant second Lieutenant
when I got stationed Fort Lewis I didn't
want to be in the Army I'm like I just
got to do my time and get out you know I
didn't like it but once 911 hit and I
went to combat when you go to combat
that's when the military kicks in that's
when you that's when you're
really you're really embedded with your
soldiers the leaders the other uh the
Marines Air Force you're everybody's
together for a purpose so all that train
you have in active duty it really hits
the it really you get it full force when
you hit combat all that training it
comes together so for me combat made me
a better officer because when you see a
lot of atrocity and soldiers dead you
can't be a clown in combat you got to
you got to make the right decision
because your decisions
depends what you yeah what you decision
you make can affect your life as well as
others so it's it's it's no joke combat
is no joke cuz nobody wants to get
injured or killed so and all the
soldiers that you know put their lives
on the line and make the ultimate
sacrifice it's uh it's incredible and I
and I want you know United Americans
have to know that's a huge that is a
huge sacrifice it's I mean to leave your
family to go fight for a cause that you
maybe not support and you get killed
doing it
so yeah our military soldiers men and
women are the are the best Americans
surely heroic loyalty
professionalism I think people should
know that you know it's our country is
the best we have the best military and
we have to make sure we have the best
leaders running it that's the
key that's it do you have regrets in
your
life yeah yeah a few regrets I was um I
was a good athlete growing up I remember
I was played basketball and baseball but
I every time I struck out if I did
something wrong I would throw the bat or
you know kick the cups I have a lot of
regrets because now I wouldn't do that
stuff if I can go back in time I would
never gave my co coaches a hard time or
you know a couple times recently I
emailed the commanders that I was in
charge they were in charge of me I was
younger and I apologized I said listen I
I know I made your life hard when I was
a lieutenant and I you know I wanted to
let them know that know they were good
officers they were good leaders is that
I was immature and I didn't
realize how important being a you know a
military officer is I was 23 years old
all I did was want to drink beer
I didn't really I didn't really know
anything about being a leader until you
I went to combat see when you when
you're with other people that are
successful and squared away it makes you
a better officer just like in life you
surround yourself with good people you
become
better if you surround myself if you sh
yourself with bad people like me when I
got out it's turned to drugs yeah so it
can really change your life so stick
with the right people and the music has
helped you steer away from music of
course yes steering away from the drugs
yes now I've been I've been clean for
actually a while now so yeah the music
helps me because I can like I go to VA a
lot 3 days a week and I play the songs
and now my music is on platforms uh
under Rob Fest um r o b two words F SS
and they're on all the music platforms
apple and all that stuff and Spotify so
I like music but I want to share my
story because
music um can help change your your life
it can change your life especially with
mental health I think music if you go
around the world music everyone comes
together for music it's amazing all over
the world musicing music brings
everybody together which is great so
yeah you want you want to play a little
something for us yeah sure finish it out
finish it out I appreciate it the
[Music]
time
[Applause]
[Music]
for
that's
it beautiful
thanks I appreciate
that yeah so music helps that's really
lovely to see thanks such a simple
natural solution to a tough problem yeah
when I play music all those all that
stuff goes away so I feel calm no
anxiety uh it's a good thing music is a
good thing
yeah um yeah I don't know what you know
without music and Al you know you have
to have a good support system so having
friends I serve with good family members
my mom you know my brother and the
people I serve with they're always there
for me if I if I have problems so which
is great I I have a good support system
but like I said when when they don't
hear from me for a week they know I
[__] up sometimes I do drugs I
disappear no phone go to go to casino
for hours once they know that happens
they're like he's list he's gone that's
it so but the music stabilizes You music
stabilizes me yeah so everywh I go
somewhere I try to find a piano anywhere
I go to hotel try to find a piano bar
with the piano so I can go play so I can
make the right decisions that's
wonderful yeah so all right Robert yeah
thank you so much appreciate thanks the
time thank you for the time and uh
allowing me the chance to share my story
where can people where can people find
your music oh yeah so it's under Rob
Fest r o b f SS two words and um I'm on
Spotify all the music platforms
YouTube uh Amazon music Apple music
Spotify and uh it's me uh walking in
front of a tank so that's the pictures
it's a military combat picture so
excellent yeah it's good stuff I
appreciate it thanks BR all right thanks
buddy